how about on the other degrees of
radicalism obviously we have blm
burning down the country that doesn't
play very well for the left but even on
some of these these wacky
sexual issues they divide us on race
they divide us on sex
on the sexual issues i don't think this
is playing well in peoria
i'll give you just an example there's a
book review out in the new york times
called
are straight people okay and other
questions about love and sexuality
based on some book castigating marriage
here's just a quick line
in examining the pressure to partner
with the opposite gender we find the
extortions of capitalism the misogyny of
violence against women
the racist and xenophobic erasure of
non-white families
and the homophobic hatreds that pervade
so much of everyday life
this is not outlier in in leftist
discourse
this is not an outlier this is the
mainstream this is what you see
broadcast during these crazy rallies
this is even what you see
on presidential debate stages among the
democratic party remember when
julian castro when he was still running
for president
he said we need to support abortion
rights we need to support abortion
justice not just for women but for trans
women
meaning men who put on dresses
who i guess can have abortions now i
don't know how that's possible
this kind of gobbledygook of leftist
jargon
the misogyny of violence against women
racist xenophobic erasure of non-white
family how do you what huh what is that
homophobic hatreds and blah blah blah
complete complete fictive gobbledygook
and i think a lot of americans who are
not
steeped in this kind of radical ideology
look at that and say huh
i got one guy telling me make america
great again i got one guy
talking to me about the erasure of the
cis
trans non-binary non-white
misogynistic blah blah blah blah blah
i think i'm going to vote for that guy
the one who i can understand you know
the one who's speaking
simple english who says like don't burn
down the country yeah i think that guy
that guy is more persuasive i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you